Speaker 1: So Eric Trump, not known
as the smartest of the Trump children,
he now made the claim that the raid, as he calls
it on Trump's Mar a Lago, will lead to a terrorist
attack. The logic there is because 30 agents were
at Mar a Lago last Monday. Then some terrorist
attack won't be prevented because everybody's too
busy. It's a very, very strange thing. I missed
this when he gave this interview. Take a look.
Speaker 3: This doesn't happen. I know,
Greg. I know this surprise very well. As you do,
this does not happen without presidential consent.
You know, the White House knew, mark my word,
they're out there today saying that no one in
the White House knew. This was 100% mark my
word, directed by the White House. This is a
political hit on my father. They know Biden's
floundering in the polls. He's doing absolutely
horrible. And so what do they do? They
put on a stunt like this. And, you know,
I want everybody to remember, God forbid, I hate
having to say this, but if there's ever another
terrorist attack in this country, if there's
ever another school shooting in this country,
the next time you see a serial killer in this
country, I want everybody to remember that the FBI
spent all their resources going into Mar a Lago
to look for, you know, effectively records for
a public library. Right. You know.
Speaker 1: Imagine a Trump library.
Everything would be written in crayon.
Speaker 3: Or then be focused on China,
who's ripping off America every single day rather
than being focused on the threats that plague this
country, terrorism that wants to come in here,
al Qaeda, you know, the Taliban, so many other
people who want to destroy our way of life,
extremists who want to destroy our way of life.
The FBI, because of Joe Biden and because
of this incompetent administration,
has weaponized the system.
Speaker 1: There's no
evidence Biden had anything to do with it.
Speaker 3: To go after their political rivals.
And that's their priority versus keeping this
country safe. I want everybody to remember that
because you better believe we're going to see
one of these instances again, and it's going to
be because their eye was off the ball. That is
a devastating way to put it. I hadn't thought
about it that way. And you are absolutely right.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the FBI is known for despite
having 35,000 employees, the FBI
only works on one case at a time.
Famous the FBI. They literally all the field
offices across the country, 35,000 employees,
one case at a time. And because they
spent a few hours at Mar a Lago,
terrorism will now not be stopped. These people
are nuts and they're dangerous. But unfortunately,
their followers hear these talking points and they
just repeat them uncritically. Let me know what
you think. Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Tomorrow, we will be joined by producer Pat,
who will be hosting the show the next couple
days. Then Farron Cousins from Ring of Fire will
be hosting a couple of days after that. And then
I will be back with stories of peace and love.
Also, remember that Wednesday, August 31st at 6
p.m. we will have the member's only David Pakman
Show Town Hall. This is a town hall like the
others we've done, except it will be open only to
members. Don't worry, we're going to get back to
the wide open town halls as well. We're just doing
one members only town hall. I would love
for you to participate and you can do so
simply by being a member at join Packman dot
com. The David Pakman Show is of course an
audience supported program you can sign up at join
Pacman dot com to become a member. Get instant
access to the bonus show and other benefits,
including members only. Town halls, the next of
which will be Wednesday, August 31st at 6 p.m.
Eastern time, which is going to be tremendous.